the game awards had some major reveals
you can play the matrix awakens unreal
engine demo now and more
the game awards 2021 featured several
big game announcements and some
unexpected surprises as well as some
much anticipated first looks at
previously announced projects now let's
talk about some of the biggest ones the
wonder woman was one of the first
surprises from the game awards 2021 and
is a new game created by monolith the
studio behind the nemesis powered middle
earth shadow of mordor and shadow of war
games little is known about the game at
the moment but the studio's reputation
speaks for itself when it comes to
crafting living breathing open worlds
developed by rocksteady games of batman
arkham fame suicide squad killed the
justice league was previously revealed
with a pre-rendered trailer however we
got our first look at gameplay during
the game awards 2021. the footage showed
harley quinn deadshot and several other
villains fighting the flash who seems to
be mind controlled and not really
feeling like himself the game is
scheduled to launch in 2022 the
long-awaited sequel alan wake 2 was
finally revealed by remedy entertainment
and this time it's going to be less
psychological thriller and more full-on
survival horror creative director sam
lake and team last made control which
made narrative connections between the
two games and it's quite possible we'll
see this expanded on in allen wick 2.
both previous allen weight games were
xbox exclusives though alan wake was
later released as a remastered game on
other platforms set in the high republic
around 200 years before luke skywalker
star wars eclipse looks to be a
different sort of star wars game and not
just because it's exploring a period we
haven't seen in other games it's
developed by quantic dream which is
known for its narrative focused
adventure games rather than action or
shooter titles how this will exactly
play out remains to be seen but the
light side and dark side concept seems
perfect for a morality system we also
got our first look at sinowa saga
hellblade 2. the gameplay was captured
the week prior to the show and looks
incredible so good that the viewers had
to be reminded before and after the
trailer that they were in fact seeing
gameplay and not cinematics only the
trailer showcases protagonist sinua
working together with a group of
warriors to take down a truly large
being of seemingly mythical origins like
the first game hellblade cinema
sacrifice it's best to experience this
new trailer with headphones on the
voices at aids cinewa speak throughout
the trailer though soft enough that it's
hard to hear them without headphones
there were plenty of reveals and
announcements and if you missed it then
be sure to check out our channel for all
of the best trailers from the show the
full replay and more
the matrix awakens is a free unreal
engine 5 experience designed to show off
the power of the engine and the
quote-unquote future of interactive
storytelling and it's now available on
both the xbox series xns and the ps5 it
was released during the game awards and
the experience was written by series
co-creator lonnie wachowski and of
course stars reeves and moss the two
appear as old versions of their matrix
characters neil and trinity albeit with
something fishy going on to explain how
they're you know alive
after a never before seen clip teased a
bit of this months of the matrix
resurrections the pair introduced the
free experience and announced that it
was already available less than a fully
fledged game the tech demo is meant to
highlight the heights now within reach
for something like unreal engine 5. just
this week epic's crown jewel fortnite
moved over to unreal engine 5 with the
launch of fortnite chapter 3. the matrix
awakens is an open world experience and
was created in collaboration between
epic games and warner brothers and comes
just weeks before the matrix
resurrections hits theaters and hbo max
on december 22nd
and speaking of new things that are now
live phasmophobia has released another
new update cursed possessions is both
the name of the new update and the name
of the new items being added to the game
these items are going to give players an
additional objective in exchange for
some information each location will
feature one of six of these new items
which are randomly chosen at the start
of each contract the new items include a
music box that paranormal entities sing
along to a tortured voodoo doll that you
can put a pin in that triggers a
reaction from the ghost a summoning
circle where you can temporarily trap a
ghost and more luigi board is now
considered a cursed possession and has
also gotten a few changes make sure you
actually say goodbye to the board or
you're going to face some consequences
along with the new cursed possessions
there is also a new ghost type the mimic
which is said to be the most intriguing
ghost type we've ever encountered has
been added to the list the mimic's
description in the journal says it's an
elusive mysterious copycat ghost that
mimics traits and behaviors from others
including other ghosts
there are also a number of other various
changes and bug fixes that you can see
on the full list on the game steam page
so what did you think of the game awards
and were there any games you were hoping
to see more of and you didn't let me
know in the comments below and make sure
you leave a like and subscribe so you
don't miss the latest in gaming news
happy friday everyone and have a great
weekend
[Music]